are you ready to return to the
Commonwealth Bethesda has a waste lands
worth of DLC plan for Fallout 4 and they
finally revealed some of it three
different expansions to be exact coming
in March is the automaton ad on this ten
dollar expansion sees the evil mechanist
unleashing his robot army onto the
Commonwealth but he's not the only one
with ro Bo buddies you can use parts to
build your own robot companions and deck
them out with armor and weapons like the
new lightning chain gun the wasteland
workshop expansion is coming in April
and five bucks gets you a new set of
workshop tools for your settlement the
big addition is cages set these up and
you'll be able to trap live animals if
you're looking to turn sanctuary Hills
into a zoo this will do it and the big
one is coming in May far Harbor may cost
twenty-five dollars but it's the biggest
landmass Bethesda has ever created for a
DLC pack this add-on takes you to Maine
on a new case from Nick Valentine's
detective agency so expect plenty of
intriguing NPCs cool quests and lots of
new armor and weapons but wait there's
more Bethesda has stated that these
three expansions are just the beginning
they're planning over sixty dollars
worth of DLC in 2016 and as such the
season pass will be shifting from thirty
dollars to fifty dollars on march first
but that's plenty of time so if these
DLC packs sound good you should probably
get on that we certainly loved fallout 4
last year so Bethesda's DLC plan will
only make things better free updates and
console mods are in the works too for
now we can all look forward to Maine
harbors cage deathclaws and lightning
chain guns on that note you can follow
me on twitter at chain gun pope and for
all the fallout news you need you're
ready in the right place